[Music]
[Music]
this is the first in a series of
lectures sponsored by the Whitehead
Institute it arose because there are now
new techniques in molecular biology that
have made it possible to diagnose hidden
genetic disorders redesigned farm
animals produce plants with new and
unusual characteristics it's clear that
these techniques will lead to new
approaches to problems outside of the
laboratory hunger environmental
pollution and disease but they also
raise important social and ethical
questions for example who will have
access to the results of genetic tests
what does it mean to patent a new
life-form how will new technologies
affect the likelihood of biological
warfare the discussions at the Institute
and specifically between Eric Lander and
myself led us to organize this series
which is titled biology in the future
basically to explore the social ethical
and environmental consequences of the
revolution in molecular biology it's
supported by a generous grant from the
Alfred P sloan Foundation with the
specific charge that we not limit this
solely to biologists for reasons that
perhaps are apparent to you and so we
have made every attempt and I believe
have succeeded in attracting people from
not only at the outside the biology
community outside of MIT to get
scientists and non-scientists here to
talk about some of these
possibilities and what lies ahead
tonight's is the first tonight's lecture
is the first of these a March 2nd
there'll be a lecture genetics and your
health
tales of genetic discrimination by Paul
Billings on April 29th the blood of our
children genetic identification of the
disappeared by maryclaire King and on
September 30th purple cows issues in
biotechnology and agriculture by Dan
catalyst and then genetic diagnostics
reading the future on November 4th the
format of this lecture is that we will
have first a presentation by dr. Matthew
meselson and then some subsequent
comments by john deutsch tonight's
speaker on the future of biological
warfare is by matthew meselson who is
the Thomas Dudley Cabot professor of the
National Sciences at Harvard University
I first learned of Matt from my genetics
textbook since he had performed the what
is now a classical experiment in
molecular biology and one that we still
teach to graduate students as the way
experiments ought to be done but Matt as
as many of you know broadened or has a
broad interest in matters of public
policy and as a consultant to the arms
control and disarmament agency in 1960s
he helped shape US policy on biological
and chemical weapons
and he is credited with being a key
influence in President Nixon's 1969
decision to renounce biological warfare
and to get rid of the u.s. stockpile of
biological microbiological weapons I
have always found Matt to be a
compelling and articulate speaker and
look forward to hearing him this evening
have a very obedient audience
the reason I accepted this invitation
was that I was invited but if I had to
justify it I would say that many of you
are biologists I'm sure they're being
such a high concentration of biologists
in this area and may want to get some
information about a subject that you
don't deal with every day but which is
still related to your work one way or
another and then more generally people
in this community must know that it is
one of the few places in the world in
which the biological revolution is
taking place and are probably interested
to know what's going on in your
community in the broadest way so what
I'm going to try to do is simply
describe some of the history and as well
as present issues in this subject and
try to be as informative as I can
why should we be concerned with this
issue of the utilization of biological
sciences for hostile purposes certainly
at the outset one has to realize that
the implications of the new biology for
human benefit are vast but it is also
true that if there should come into play
large scale or serious exploitation
deliberate exploitation of biology for
hostile purposes that this could cause
great harm over the short run the kind
of harm that's easy to envisage and
described in detail derives from the
fact that at least in principle though
no one has ever done it and maybe an
attempt to do it would fizzle but
nevertheless potentially with biological
weapons based on infectious organisms it
could be possible to cause illness and
death over very large areas with
relatively small payloads the reason for
this is simply that the mass the weight
of infectious agent that it is required
to initiate an infection
human being is a very small mass anyone
number is going to be misleading because
there are so many variables starting
with how many organisms are required to
initiate an infection say by the aerosol
route in by inhalation there's great
variation in this number depending on
the organism in question even with a
fairly homogeneous population for
example just a very few cells of the
organism that causes tularemia Francis
la2 Aransas three four five cells
probably are enough to initiate an
infection
whereas with another organism bacillus
anthracis the agent of anthrax maybe ten
maybe 50,000 spores are required before
there's a 50% likelihood of infecting a
primate we don't do experiments
experiments like that haven't been done
on human beings and recorded or known to
me so there's variation there there are
many other uncertainties stability of
the organism susceptibility of a
population distribution modalities so
any one number is unlikely to mean much
nevertheless even if one allows for all
the variabilities it's pretty clear that
relatively small quantities some have
said maybe is smaller weight per area
made lethal to be in as say hydrogen
bombs maybe a greater weight maybe a
smaller weight but perhaps in that
ballpark certainly much smaller weights
than would be required to attack people
with conventional weapons or with
chemical weapons simply because of the
fact that a single organism weighing
about 10 to the minus 12 grams or a few
dozen organisms given the right
infectious organism could initiate an
infection so this means that in
relatively simple not totally simple and
not totally cheap but relatively
compared to other kinds of weapons that
have strategic effects over large areas
biological weapons could be a very
serious strategic threat either for
intimidation or for actually causing
disease there is possible a protection
if you're wearing a simple air filter
but the problem is that for the attack
of large populations unless they're worn
unless they were equipped there they
could be very vulnerable so that is a
short description of the kind of hazard
that's easy to see today if there were
deliberate intense exploitation of
bacteriology for military purposes the
future potential for danger is harder
and more foggy to describe and in fact
I'm going to swing all the way to a very
distant future and say something it may
sound very foggy to some of you and that
is that we've gone through many
different technological ages muscle
power fire the power of fire then
coupled via various agencies esteem than
an electronic age of nuclear agent all
of these technologies do get used for
hostile purposes as well as for
constructive purposes some people might
feel and I'm one of them and I should
admit this up front that those methods
of waging war or more amorphous kinds of
hostile action against other members of
our species are somehow survivable
compared to what would happen if we used
our knowledge of ourselves if we use the
kind of knowledge of life processes that
is beginning to accumulate not very much
of it yet but more and more rapidly and
will become increasingly profound until
we understand all of the life processes
including those of development and of
the brain that if this kind of knowledge
is deliberately used for hostile
purposes on any significant scale that
we could be in a kind of trouble as a
species that's very different from the
kinds of trouble we
could have gotten into with other kinds
of scientific violence and not just in
over at war but in other areas in which
human hostility can be manifested well
so much for the ball gazing in the
philosophy I'd like now to try to give
you a short historical sketch of this
subject before World War one and II even
in World War one there wasn't much
really going on in the area of
biological warfare after all the whole
idea of infectious organisms in the
isolation of pure cultures wasn't much
pasture coke wasn't much before World
War one and although there were some
biological warfare attempts small-scale
giving horses glanders some things like
that it wasn't until World War two that
it really got going but during World War
two there were sizable biological
warfare programs in Great Britain the
United States Germany Japan Canada and
almost certainly the Soviet Union and we
will find out about that as I'll explain
later we hope very soon we know most
about the United States program because
the United States has by far more than
the Canadians more than the British more
than the Japanese more than Germany been
open about what it was that we were
doing up until the Year 1969 lots of
different organisms were screened to see
which would be most effective for
aerosol dissemination aerosol
dissemination was the main mode of
dissemination that was investigated it
was early on realized that it was by far
the most effective if one was what had
affected masada biological weapons as
strategic weapons by the time that
President Nixon ordered our stockpiles
destroyed we had gone through several
different infectious organism
standardized them and then declared the
mob's elite but the ones that were
standardized and stockpiled at that time
were francis sell it to Aransas
that's the organism that causes
tularemia maybe four or five cells
though I don't know how reliable these
numbers extrapolated from
quite different situation would be but
it was thought that a small number of
organisms would be infectious and we had
a large stockpile coxiella Brunetti
Rickettsia that causes Q fever and
Venezuelan equine encephalitis a virus
that was categorized as a incapacitating
rather than a lethal biological weapon
so we had stockpiles of these things and
there were also stockpiles of wheat rust
and rice blast to anti crop fungal
agents the scale of this effort was
pretty big for example at Pine Bluff
there were separate facilities for each
infectious organism in the late 50s one
of the facilities there for growing
Rickettsia it's called the x201 facility
it was fairly big it employed more than
800 people used 2 million gallons of
water a day five megawatts of
electricity lots of steam it was big
partly because at least at that time it
was not possible reliably to store these
agents for very long periods and keep
them infectious and so the idea was to
have a pretty big capacity that could be
put online quickly
generally speaking protection wasn't
available to civilian populations
it still isn't it would be a big chore
as I indicated although conceivably it
could be done if there was a sense of
acute danger maintained detectors
diagnosis gas masks alarms discipline
and so on but the capability of the
United States at that time was offensive
but as it is today hardly any defensive
capability at least in the narrow sense
of the word I should know digress
slightly and say how I got interested in
this it was by total accident during the
summer of 1963 as I only recently
learned there was a budget surplus at
the United States arms control and
disarmament agency and there was the
alternative of giving it back or
figuring out something to do it and so
the Science and Technology branch
director of the time an excellent
chemist from Montana decided to use it
and he invited a group of academics I
shared an office with Freeman
Dyson and we were told do whatever you
want yeah just do something and I said
well that's not I don't know what should
i do I went down there just because I
thought it would be interesting to see a
completely different kind of human
activity from molecular biology and just
for a summer I didn't think it would
risk losing more than a summer and so I
was told well why don't you look into
theater nuclear arms-control in Europe
and I tried that for a couple of weeks
and then it dawned on me slowly - slowly
that there were already lots of people
in the field and I've never liked to be
in a field where there too many other
people and they had written wisely about
the subject and unwisely about the
subject and there was a lot known and in
two or three months there's no way that
I could do anything useful for the
United States government so I went to by
Boston said well I'm a chemist and a
biologist haven't you got something for
me
that would draw on what I know he said
yeah we had a guy who did that he was
from Caltech - he got depressed and he
killed himself but you could have his
desk so I did and that is I took his
desk and at first I thought well I'll
deal with this subject and then I
realized that that was even that was too
big a subject for just a summer so I put
the larger of the two aside that was
chemical weapons and concentrated on
biological weapons so I went to Fort
Detrick to see what we were doing this
was 1963 and I went to the CIA to see
what we thought other people were doing
and I talked to lots of people and I
came to a rather simple conclusion
probably too simple but it was this it
sort of went like a series of
propositions what can you do with
biological weapons you can kill people
or threatened to kill them over very big
areas hundreds of square kilometers the
United States can already do that the
way that we can do it or could have done
it can't still do it it was very
expensive and very technologically
sophisticated namely nuclear weapons why
should we be the ones to introduce a
cheap way of doing the same thing what
capability would it add for us
other people yes they would have a new
capability if we were to pioneer the
development of biological weapons
besides usually what the United States
does gets to be known around the world
with a small time lag so the possibility
of doing it all in secret in fact there
were officer chemical warfare officers
that were writing books praising it
because it would save money and I
concluded that the cheaper it was the
worse it was and we should definitely
stop it completely and instead just
concentrate on watching as carefully as
we could what other people were doing
discouraging it and thinking about what
to do if it should ever break loose but
nobody at that time felt that there was
enough time on their schedule no one
high up enough to do much about it when
President Nixon was elected for various
various things conspired to cause a
review to be ordered by by the president
and this was a very interesting review
there are different kinds of reviews I
suppose sometimes you review something
because you don't want to do anything
about it so you review it sometimes you
review something because you've already
decided what you want to do about it but
you review it so that it looks like
you're thinking about all the different
arguments and trying to get all the
facts and then sometimes you would
review something when you really thought
you ought to look into it and didn't
know what it all was all meant and what
you should do I could be wrong but I
think this review was of the Third Kind
and it was done in a style that may have
been at least in some of those reviews
characteristic of Henry Kissinger which
I thought was a very admirable style and
that was each agency of the government
was not only asked but there was
insistence that it explained not only
what it thought was this best policy but
give the pros and cons for all the other
policies so this enabled relatively
junior staff people from the National
Security Council to go over to the Joint
Chiefs for example or to a CDA or an
estate and say well gentlemen you've
done an excellent job here of explaining
your preferred option now when it comes
down to this option number two you you
have
given a very good argument for it
because that wasn't what they wanted so
naturally they didn't give a good
argument for it but because of this
ground rule that you had to give the
president every option and you had to
argue every option pros and cons which
so far as I know maybe didn't happen in
many reviews this is the only review at
that level that I've had much to do it
but I thought it was pretty pretty
excellent and I do know that what
President Nixon got had all the options
and all the arguments that at least I
could ever imagine pro and con and he
decided something more sweeping than I
think most of us expected he decided to
get rid of the biological warfare
program completely he was offered many
options he was told you could renounce
it if someone else namely the Soviets
are willing to do that there'd be a quid
pro quo or you could renounce it but
mothball it don't renounce the option
just get rid of the program or tune it
down it was running at a pretty fast
clip in those days but keep the option
he rejected it completely and ordered
that the program be stopped and that the
United States renounced its right ever
to use biological weapons and then
during a backgrounder
some journalists asked Henry Kissinger
well what about toxins and there's a
there's a verbatim text of this and
Kissinger says what are toxins and
journalists didn't know either someone
had fed him the question
and it turned out the NSC staff had
written a lot about toxins but the head
of that particular review saw how long
it was and how technical it looked and
said take this reduce this and so what
went to the president about toxins was
really very brief and it got left out
and so a whole new review was ordered up
about toxins and again the president was
offered a whole range of options from
toxins are not living they do not
reproduce you know toxins are defined as
poisonous things poisonous chemicals
they don't reproduce their chemicals but
that are made by living things
so the Clostridium botulinum makes a
nasty toxin called botulin yeast makes a
pleasurable toxin called ethanol it's
still a toxin in the sense that it in
appropriate dose can be harmful and it's
made by a living thing anyway the one
option was toxins are not infectious
they're not b/w you're not going to
renounce them another was toxins if made
by living things because bacteria make
toxins and that's getting close to
sounding like disease again would be
prohibited and renounced but if the
chemists over there can learn how to
synthesize them that would be okay
another option was no will renounced
them under all circumstances but we
won't renounce the right to use them in
future if other people do and then
finally it is extreme exceedingly
left-wing alternative renounce them no
matter how they're made and renounced
them in perpetuity and that's what
President Nixon did the first decision
about infectious agents in 1969 November
and the second one about toxins after
someone asked what are toxins in 1970
and this really got the United States
out of the business we destroyed our
stockpiles we converted the laboratories
at Pine Bluff to the study of toxic
substances in the laboratories at Fort
Detrick in the production facilities and
the laboratories at Fort Detrick to
cancer research and other things there
were kept at those sites things military
units that did other things and the
biological defense
enterprise but not making weapons at
Fort Detrick and also a biological
defensively oriented facility at Dugway
in Utah but the offensive program was
really extirpated gone then there came
up the question well how about a treaty
well we'd already given it up and not
only that we'd renounce the option so
treaty then would be only a bonus if
people didn't obey it that wouldn't be
so good but since it didn't require us
to do anything we weren't gonna do
anyway why not and the British had
proposed such a treaty and so at the
same time the president renounced BW he
announced support for that British draft
treaty which fight which is called the
biological weapons convention of 1972
today there are about a hundred parties
to it it prohibits the the production
prohibits the development production
possession transfer etc of biological
agents for any but peaceful purposes it
didn't have any verification attached to
it but it did have a an article which
required a review conference after five
years and it's become customary to have
review conferences periodically there
have now been three and these review
conferences have achieved what some
would call a little bit of verification
and what others would call some
confidence-building the first review
conference in 1980 didn't accomplish
very much this was at the time shortly
after in December that the Soviets had
invaded Afghanistan the Cold War was
very bitter spared lost there had been
an outbreak of anthrax and to become
known in the West in April of 1979
became known in the West shortly yeah
after that and these subjects dominated
much of the debates at that first review
conference but the second one in 1986
did achieve something the parties to the
biological weapons convention agreed
that they would declare the location
ownership size and general purpose of
all p4 facilities p4 as you know is a
high level of containment for
exceedingly dangerous infectious agents
and that they would also declare the
location etc of all p3 facilities if
they were engaged in work of direct
relevance to the biological weapons
convention and percent pursuant to that
these declarations which the United
States and the Soviet Union and Great
Britain in many countries but also many
didn't but many countries every April of
15th they're supposed to renew their
declarations and this has been going on
ever since the United States and the
Soviet Union have been filing these
declarations the third review conference
was last year in 1991 and it added some
more measures States Parties to the
convention which as I say has about 120
parties today agreed that they would
describe their biological defense
programs they're not supposed to have
biological offense programs to be no
point asking to describe those but their
biological defense programs namely how
they're organized actually giving names
of people in charge of the major
components what their facilities are and
so on
now you could dodge this you could say
it's actually my cotton candy program
it's not a biological defense program at
all it's something else but it allows
one to compare both what you know and
what you fear with what is declared and
by comparison of this information it's
possible to derive conclusions about
compliance or about non-compliance they
may not be rock-solid but they're better
than the conclusions that you could
otherwise make a very interesting
agreement was that all states parties
agreed to submit by April 15th of this
year income tax day a description of
their biological warfare activities
beginning in the year 1946 so we're
waiting very eagerly do we know what the
United States was doing since 1946
pretty much but there are a lot of
countries which never said anything the
Soviet Union has said when there was a
Soviet Union that they were in
compliance but it will be very
interesting to find out what they say
they were doing beginning in 1946 and
there's some other governments too will
be interesting to know what they say
and that was agreed to have a further
meeting very soon not with the usual
five-year wait in fact this march of
experts to discuss possible methods of
verification there's a disagreement here
the United States generally has argued
to some extent it's a hangover from the
ideological days of the Reagan
administration but to some extent it
there's a lot of merit to it that and it
doesn't matter whether you say a ban on
biological weapons is unverifiable or
it's not verifiable enough
it's theology to try to make that
distinction but the United States is
argue that it's not verifiable enough to
have a verification regime so we could
call them confidence-building measures
instead I think at some points it ends
up as a quibble except for a concept
that is pretty obvious but I would like
to take a minute and talk about it and
that is yes it could be difficult to
verify a biological disarmament treaty
although there are things you can look
for if you know where to look certain
kinds of storage facilities arrow arrow
biology aerosolization chambers what
kind what size what precautions studies
of non-endemic pathogens why are you
studying that you don't have that in
your country the explanation is
reasonable fine if not keep asking
questions very large scale production
units though those may exist for other
purposes to trace the organization and
financing look for test grounds and so
on and so forth but there's another way
not to exclude those others but there's
another way of dealing with this kind of
problem that is based on the assumption
that nobody's going to develop
biological weapons in the open you're
not supposed to do it so you shouldn't
do it publicly therefore that would mean
that if you could verify openness then
you would be verifying compliance
maybe openness could be viewed as a real
object like a cube of platinum can't you
verify openness yes there are ways you
can verify openness for example much
better than checking on the volume of
their aerosol chambers if my daughter
was the biological safety officer at a
suspect facility and considering how
Snoopy
I'm not insulting anybody biological
safety officers are they go into
everything I feel very happy about that
facility I'd say there's nothing there
can't be anything wrong there if she's
there um and she talks to me on the
phone I can tell her voice it's not
funny she comes home for visits I go
there and see her what I'm getting at is
that the exchange of personnel there's
an awfully good way to verify openness
and especially certain kinds of
personnel and there are other ways and
probably some ingenious ways that
haven't been thought of but a verifying
openness as an entity so that you don't
have to get down to the little details
of well they haven't got one of those
and then someone says but maybe they
have one of these and they could do the
job with one of those instead of that
and so on okay
so although this treaty is not one which
has all kinds of rigorous verification
attached to it it is one to which have
been added and now with the changed
world environment we hope there will be
added more and more measures of openness
and of confidence-building and since we
don't want anything to do with
biological weapons I hope that none of
our officials want anything to do with
biological weapons except for a few
Souls at relatively low levels I've
never met anybody who seems to want to
anymore um we're out of it anyway maybe
there are some things we should be doing
we should be interested in methods of
rapid diagnosis we should be interested
in how to make vaccines and how to make
some of them quickly we should have a
good epidemiological surveillance
service I think ours in recent years
just slipped a bit we should be doing
those things there are some things that
are arguable that we do I won't get into
those there are you on both sides but
what I would assert very strongly is we
shouldn't do anything that isn't open it
should be open there are some slight
risks and openness if you're working on
defense and diagnosis and detection but
I think that so long as you try and get
quid pro quos get other people open but
be willing to open yourself that you're
ahead
know what things are there to watch
coming up in this area of biological
hostility well we could start with Iraq
we thought that there might be a hazard
emanating from Iraq to the extent that
we vaccinated soldiers against bacillus
anthracis and some of them against
botulinum watch Lynas toxin i thought i
was going to be on that UN team for a
while so I was vaccinated with bacillus
anthracis though there was a concern on
the part of several countries that maybe
there was a program there and it turns
out according to the Iraqis now that
there was a program they say that it was
at the research level and nothing has
been detected in the nature of an actual
weapons production or weapons filling
they say that they did have a military
program though their declaration says
that they worked with bacillus anthracis
with Clostridium botulinum and
Clostridium perfringens the latter to
making toxins and anthrax being an
infectious organism of which many of you
I think know a little bit about it
lethal
infectious is a lethal disease that can
be spread by inhalation or ingestion so
they were working on these things and
there was a a secured refrigerated
storage facility that you could argue
might have might have had in mind doing
something bad with it that's all the UN
has found today but there was some work
going on in the next few weeks we should
be learning more about what went on in
the Soviet Union as I say there is a
requirement for declaration on April 15
and you've probably read in the
newspapers that Boris Yeltsin and his
military adviser on his recent trip to
United States have spoken to American
officials about some things which they
say went beyond what the treaty would
have allowed and we'll see what those
were we might even see though perhaps
less political incentive for us
admissions of error in some things that
we have said particularly I have in mind
the allegation that we made again and
again in
unfortunately even repeated this last
year in what's called the president's
annual non-compliance statement the
allegation that somebody was practicing
mycotoxin try co-teaching mycotoxin
warfare in Southeast Asia so far as I
know that yellow rain story was just
completely wrong there was no such
there's no as far as I know no good
evidence for it and a lot of evidence of
the presence of poor reasoning and poor
data and even misuse of science in that
story there'll be the March verification
conference in Geneva and that might
agree on further measures of
verification or I don't expect anything
major from it but rather something in
the nature of slow progress towards
further opening and confidence-building
there's something big though that's on
the horizon and that's the Chemical
Weapons Convention and it's related to
biological weapons because of toxins now
I haven't said much about toxins yet so
now I should I'm going to choose to do
that in the course of making comments
about what some people say is the
possible impact of new biology and
making more effective biological weapons
I've never believed that recombinant DNA
technology or new biological technology
would make infectious organisms into a
much worse threat than they already are
now there are two ways of understanding
that or there's really one way of
understanding it one way of
misunderstanding it one way of
misunderstanding it does it say these
things aren't threatening with either
old biology or new biology that's not
what I mean
what I mean is in the old ones though no
one ever did it but very good chance
that the old ones were already bad
enough that Pasteurella to the rancis an
awful lot of research was done on it
[Music]
you'd have to write down a list of
things that would make it more
threatening and I would look at it and I
don't think I would find it more
threatening for organisms well so you
might develop something one organism is
enough it's no difference it's fairly
stable etc etc so I've never agreed that
recombinant DNA
technology makes infectious biological
warfare look that much more ominous in
any practical sense that anyone has ever
been able to describe to me about toxins
to some extent or a different matter by
the way on infectious organisms I should
say though that recombinant DNA
technology or more modern methods of
doing biological research can make
better vaccines and make we haven't got
many yet but but in principle can make
vaccines better can can make them easier
now that's on the defensive side not the
offensive sorry but toxins are something
else again there are toxins that are
very poisonous getting them to act
through the skin and after all there are
chemical weapons nerve agents that are
also also also very poisonous and they
do go through the skin and very stable
and they don't burn up when they are
detonated with an explosive and
militarily they have all kinds of
advantages if that's what one is after
and toxins don't get you much beyond
that and they don't go through the skin
but in principle maybe someone could
engine near them or mix them or get them
to do that and you could go to higher
levels of toxicity with toxins and so on
and there's some other things you can
say about them so maybe there is some
room if you really want biological
weapons to do something with toxins if
you felt you one of them but the
Chemical Weapons Convention which is now
I finished a few technical remarks I had
about toxins covers toxins as well as
other chemicals and it's a very amazing
convention and we're going to get it
probably it will be initialed this year
I say we're going to get it I would be
surprised if we don't it looks very much
as though we will this is a treaty which
will involve many nations it's a
multilateral treaty that states parties
will agree to declare and then destroy
their present holdings of poison gas
weapons chemical weapons to destroy
their facilities for making them and to
institute a verification regime which
far from perfect nevertheless will
certainly raise the likelihood of
getting caught if you want to cheat and
will constitute some kind of deterrent
and
over time we'll reinforce or create and
reinforce a norm against the use of
toxic weapons and we'll also provide a
model or better yet a test or an
experiment of whether we really are
anywhere near a New World Order
something in which it's possible to act
more cooperatively than in the past to
achieve security the Chemical Weapons
Convention will do all of those things
if it succeeds I have one great concern
about it which is a little bit off my
topic tonight but I do want to pass it
on to you because I'm concerned about it
nearly all nations have the view that
nearly all nations that have expressed a
view on this that the Geneva Protocol
prohibits the use of all toxic chemicals
as means of war and that would include
incapacitating chemicals as well as
lethal ones the United States has
renounced lethal chemicals and has
renounced so-called incapacitating
chemicals but has not renounced the use
of what are called riot control agents
in warfare there are some reasons why
riot control agents can be useful in
warfare we used about 8,000 tons of them
in Vietnam never essentially once I
believe for separating civilians from
soldiers you know the overwhelming
majority of cases in order to enhance
mobility or firepower dropping CS before
bombing runs and using CS in 155
artillery projectiles and so on and it
can be I think marginally useful to the
side that uses it especially if the
other side doesn't use it but it is a
kind of chemical warfare soldiers are
wearing gas masks military
establishments are learning how to make
offensive use of toxic chemicals that go
through the air establishments back home
are becoming dependent for budgets and
careers and so on on a roll for toxic
things and so on in this new convention
in the article which defines what
chemicals are to be prohibited there is
a bracketed pair of sentences put there
by the United States which would totally
exempt
all chemicals with a lethality below 10
milligrams per kilogram body weight of
Sprague Dawley rat from the convention
if they are used by a state party also
for law enforcement or police purposes
domestically this bothers me there's now
research going on to try and get riot
control agents that are better than CS
which incidentally stands for the two
harvard chemists who first synthesized
it course and installing it doesn't last
very long for example there's the whole
family of opioids synthetic compounds
like heroin sometimes mistakenly called
china white china white is really real
heroin a very pure kind but these
fentanyl like compounds are synthetic
analogues and there's work going on now
to try and develop these as weapons the
idea would be to release them as an
aerosol and people would be knocked out
a problem with this is that although
these are the kinds of compounds that
are used in darts to capture wild
animals it doesn't work on primates
because they're more sensitive to the
respiratory arrest properties of these
fentanyl compounds these open synthetic
opioids and so they're lethal too often
they would be lethal too often in
practice for primates including humans
primates and so there's research trying
to mix them with antidotes
against their respiratory effects but to
maintain their knock out effects and one
has to agree that there are military
situations in which one side or another
might use such a weapon to some
advantage the treaty protects all
peaceful purposes and police purposes
and riot control purposes of chemicals
that's not an issue what is at issue is
the united states policy which at the
moment at least and our negotiators in
geneva will tell you that this policy is
absolutely non-negotiable unless the
President himself changes it
insists that if a chemical is used for
domestic law enforcement by a state
party then that chemical may be used
freely without the restraints in which
we now by the way do impose ourselves
those restraints would be gone that
chemical could be used freely in war
that I think could be a big mistake
because it's a loophole now an
incapacitating gas is a long way from a
lethal one and it's some distance away
from a biological agent and that's some
distance away from a lethal biological
infectious agent but both the pattern of
proliferation in the world and in the
thinking of many people there is a kind
of linkage amongst all these infectious
and toxic all of these things which take
advantage of the inner life processes
all these things which could be
developed and perfected over time by
deeper knowledge of our own living
systems people tend to think of these as
a unit and I don't know if fine
distinctions would last very long if one
nation or another insisted on using just
that end of the spectrum that was useful
for it especially if the other nations
have to be dragged along to make that
distinction so I hope that doesn't
happen so I really come to the end and I
hope I have left time for questions I'd
like to end by saying and really
repeating what I said before that it
might be wise now at the very beginning
of the real revolution in biology just
to put a hold on all the hostile uses of
our relatively new science we don't lose
much by doing that and we might gain a
great deal
[Applause]
[Music]
our discussant for the Matt stalk is
John Deutsch who's served as MIT Provost
from 1985 until 1990 he is currently
Institute professor here at MIT in
August of 1990 George Bush appointed
John Deutsch to the president's foreign
intelligence advisory board he's also
served on the defense policy board and
defense Science Board you can read a
great deal of his public service in
these areas in the in the biography here
I was particularly anxious to have John
be here because Matt is such a
compelling speaker that I always feel
after hearing him that I now agree
completely with what he said and
whenever I get into a situation of
thinking I really know what the right
course is I talked to John Deutsch and
he convinces me that that's completely
wrong so I think John is in the spirit
of the Henry Kissinger's
options and in that spirit of making us
think about something else other
possibilities I'm very happy to welcome
John as discussing
[Applause]
Thank You Jerry I'm pleased to learn
that I was invited to participate this
evening because perhaps I could offer
some interesting views in a contrast to
the fact that I'm not a biologist and
would satisfy the terms of the grant
under which these I'm also very pleased
to appear at the same time as matt
meselson matt has dedicated himself to
study of the subjects of biological and
chemical warfare as he's described I
think scrupulously and very carefully
for a guess about 30 years now and that
serves the public well and we have every
great reason to listen to him carefully
and to be pleased that there's so many
on our community who is taking the pains
to follow such important matters I don't
believe that I'm going to stand here
before you with a long list of the items
under which I disagree about the
subjects with Jim mattis and rest
what I do want to do is perhaps spend a
moment touching on a few of the points
which were brought up let me begin
though with bringing you some bad news
and some good news the bad news is that
I believe that the world is entering a
period where of a proliferation of
weapons of mass destruction there's
going to be a significantly larger
concern that it has been in the past
several decades when we've been really
moderately fortunate that the slow pace
at which weapons of mass destruction
have diffused throughout nations in the
world a lot of reasons for that I don't
want to dwell on them I think it's
partially but not entirely connected
with the collapse of the former Soviet
Union but there is also a growing
regional instability in the world which
leads countries to sink
unfortunately weapons of mass
destruction quite independent of what
the United States the former Soviet
Union or other you
peon or Japan what a would apparently
what they do now these weapons of mass
destruction are three varieties there
are nuclear weapons chemical weapons and
the biological weapons of which Matt
principally addressed that's the bad
news I think in a very very serious
problem it is a principal problem I
would say that should be on the foreign
policy agenda of the United States
currently with the happy loss of the
political competition with the Soviet
Union that is really bad news and I
would like to spend some time mentioning
to you talking to you about this issue
of proliferation the good news is for
those of you who are rather more
conservative the principal topic to this
evening's conversation that I just don't
think modern biology is going to be a
central player in this variety for some
period of time and I'm thinking that
Matt and I share but you just don't need
a lot better or worse than what you
already have slightly better living
organisms still are inconvenient to
manage and handle and not militarily
useful in my view and there's really no
purpose in developing them complex
toxins developed maybe by biotechnology
techniques of genetic engineering in the
future strike me as being still having
to compete with rather awesome
organophosphate nerve agents which are
present in quantity and easy to produce
odorless colorless and have the ability
to survive and some of them have the
ability to survive in some climates so I
really do not believe that we run the
risk here as we do perhaps in other
subjects that this symposium will be
addressing in the seminar will be
addressing on future evenings of say
that molecular biology has a particular
mod in biology has a particular problem
here but I do think that we have jointly
at issue whether you call it new biology
or not to worry about the proliferation
of nuclear chemical weapons
destruction especially in regions of the
world that are highly unstable and prone
to violence when I look at the lesson of
Iraq of the war in Iraq it has it bears
on this subject I find that there are
three points of great importance first I
think that it is shocking and scandalous
that the world stood by while there was
an all-out war between Iran and Iraq and
saw the fairly widespread use of
chemicals in that more causing really
substantial numbers of fatalities and
injuries and in no way in no diplomatic
way much less any more forceful means
intervened in that conflict I think that
the absence of intervention and the
iraq-iran war in the matter of the use
of chemicals did indeed provide a lesson
an unfortunate lesson for nations of the
world that I might regard as rogue
States it gave them a greater interest
in weapons of mass destruction second
point I would like to make about the
iran-iraq war has to do with the
enormous era of US intelligence or US
policy with respect to what was going on
in Iran and Iraq and indeed the era
occurred with opposite sign in the case
of nuclear and in the case of chemical
and biological in the case of nuclear
weapons the estimates before the war and
in fact during the war were that Iraq
had was a signatory I might add of the
non-proliferation treaty Iraq who is a
signatory of the non-proliferation
treaty and who's won declared nuclear
facility was indeed inspected and
properly inspected by the International
Atomic Energy Agency but the official
estimate and the policy view was that
while they certainly had a covert
nuclear weapons program that it was R&D
modest and scale and so forth point of
fact is now quite completely apparent
with the quite successful I guess have
been 10 up till now IAEA
actions of Iraq they had an absolutely
massive program from soup to nuts for
mining or all the way to explore
experimenting with sophisticated means
of enriching uranium to obtain highly
enriched uranium football news they had
somewhere between ten and fifteen
thousand trained scientists and
engineers working in this program it was
not a little site that it was a enormous
venture which were completely escaped
reporting not only of the United States
and its intelligence services but
similarly the reporting of the
intelligence services of the French the
British the Russians and the Israelis to
the extent that you can believe the
information they provide in that case we
had an enormous underestimate of what
was going on in Iraq a country which was
at that time had a major nuclear weapons
program I do not want to suggest you
that they were eight months through six
months or five days away from having a
bomb what I do want to say is that a
very serious program you have at this
very moment the similar discussion going
on with North Korea there is great
concern about what is happening in
Algeria there's concern about what is
happening Iran and there was concern
about what is happening is certainly in
Libya on that side we underestimated
dramatically what was going on in
nuclear nuclear matters in the case of a
nuclear proliferation treaty signatory
in Iraq on the chemical side we
estimated we estimated that the Iraqis
had and had deliverable chemicals in a
variety of forms including on Scud
missiles and then if the United States
forces if United States forces joined
with them in the desert that they would
use these chemical agents against US
forces Matt has described to you quite
correctly it was also a concern that
they had biological agent anthrax and
botulinum but this would be potentially
used against US servicemen and there was
a desolate Ori program to inoculate them
during the
campaign it turned out of course that
the Iraqis did not use their chemical
weapons indeed it is a striking feature
that mr. Saddam Hussein to the best of
my knowledge did not deploy any chemical
munitions of which he had many and we
now know that he had at least thirty
Scud warheads that were available to use
including binary agent warhead but he
did not deploy any of these chemical
weapons into the Kuwaiti theater of
operations or anywhere near Basra or
south of Basra and that therefore he was
much more reluctant or unable to argue
it either way but certainly there was
some initial reluctance of him to deploy
these weapons so that in this case there
was an instance of enormous enormous
overestimating how likely chemical
weapons were to be used point I want to
make is not to argue the rights or
wrongs of either one of those pictures
but to indicate how absolutely difficult
it is going to be in a time when we are
trying to slow the proliferation of
these weapons of mass destruction to
assess properly and at a policy level
what the picture is before one
intervenes at a diplomatic matter
especially if one wants to intervene the
diplomatic manner in concert with other
nations perhaps through the UN perhaps
through some other agency in a matter
like this and as I say the matter is
presently an identical case occurs in
North Korea where we have astonishing
with little information about what is
influencing the North Korean government
the reason I raised this is to know we'd
like to conclude by making a comment
about the multilateral chemical treaty
it is indeed the most important the most
significant I should say the most
significant arms control measure in this
area that is on the agenda I would say
for the next five or ten years for a
variety of purposes
the multilateral the chemical treaty is
a treaty which is a great interest to
this administration it has the support
of the President and I would bet more
even
more than even money that that treaty
will be passed what concerns me about
that treaty is the following while it is
a measure that I support I think it's a
reasonable thing to take for the United
States to enter into and to encourage
within the community of nations
it does have several very very severe
weaknesses and I mentioned them only two
in passing the first is that there is
really an issue of verification it is
extremely difficult as I've tried to
illustrate with my remarks about Iraq
very very difficult to know that one has
an accurate picture even with very
sophisticated intelligence gathering and
other information gathering techniques
very sophisticated means it isn't very
difficult to know what is going on
especially covertly in a nation a nation
not the friendly nation but a nation
that sees itself having security
concerns and maybe having less than
friendly intentions towards its neighbor
second is that that treaty does not
really as I understand it contain no
first use a no first use declaration by
all of its members I believe it should
nor does the treaty agree nor does the
treaty agree to what the signatories
will do if somebody either violates the
treaty or proceeds to use chemicals even
if they are not members of the tree and
until the issue of sanctions is agreed
upon by those people who enter into the
multilateral chemical treaty I think
that we will have stopped short of
taking a multilateral step that will
indeed effectively slow the spread of
chemical weapons because as matters
stand now the world has the lesson first
of iran-iraq war where chemicals were
freely used and know everybody stood by
and the second we have the example of
the Iraq war itself
the most recent conflict in the Gulf
where indeed we had a signatory to the
non-proliferation treaty who was from
violating the non-nuclear part of the
treaty the nuclear non-proliferation
treaty and was not being brought to bear
for it by any inspection scheme that was
present in some the multilateral treaty
and my judgment needs to have
strengthening along the lines that I've
mentioned no first use some discussion
and agreement among its members about
what sanctions will be taken in case
someone does violate that treaty
why doesn't that take place why doesn't
that take place the reason that there is
not such an agreement why that is not
included in the treaty my judgement is
the policymakers today in the United
States in Washington or elsewhere across
the globe face two questions and have no
good answers to those questions the
first question is how do you determine
proliferation how do you slow the spread
and I must say that I think since 1974
the last time we had for example a
detonation of a nuclear weapon by a
country India there are probably three
new members of the nuclear Club
certainly Israel South Africa and
Pakistan we don't know how to slow that
spread you don't have those slow that
spread in the nuclear area much more
difficult in the chemical biological
area and secondly if we arrive at a
situation where somebody does
proliferate we have no effective policy
measures of knowing what to do about in
a political matter thank you very much
[Applause]
with men yes I can ask both of our
speakers to come up to the front I'm
sure that there are many questions from
the audience I know some people will
need to leave there but the speakers
have agreed to stay on for about 10 or
15 minutes of questions we have a
microphone down here for those who want
to use it for those with loud voices I'm
willing to recognize people anywhere in
the audience if they don't want to come
down to use it the first question over
there oh and could I ask you because
this is such a diverse audience we've
tried to attract to say who you are and
where you're from because I think would
be nice for us to know the range of
people have come today
well I must admit to scholarly
deficiency I have not kept so close to
the BW convention and the subsequent
negotiations to no working even describe
to you reliably why our position is so
strong on incapacitating agents the
apocryphal story the past was at the MIT
that the police chief of New Orleans was
really insisted on keeping busy I guess
is what it was which is tear dad's et tu
guys
CS is tear gas available for domestic
use and at that time there was a
confusion about if he used it
domestically for civilian control
purposes whether you would have a right
to use it the military but I want to
tell you this is not a big deal with me
and I would guess that if somebody put
their mind to it we could probably
change them you could probably get the
position the United States changed I
don't think it's a big I can't see where
are the government there's going to be a
real hard over you want this so to me
it's not a big deal and apocryphally
it's because of the mayor the police
chief of New Orleans that's the answer
in the first question
second question I think that the is a
little bit more complicated I do not
believe it would be in the United States
interest and I believe the president
declared this quite clearly that if
chemicals had been used against US
forces in the Middle East
I would not believe that the president
would have or should have used nuclear
weapons in response and you might say to
me it doesn't matter what you think
we'll believe it's what size but I do I
think I want to tell you the issue with
the United States is a little bit more
dicey because I think we have to worry
about how we deter use against our own
forces overseas or our own cities if you
like but not saying the way we deterrent
is I think of mindless and quite frankly
not quite credible say will hit you with
nuclear weapons I don't think that
that's an adequate response for us on
the other hand I'm quite happy to
believe that if one of those scuds with
chemical weapons for a variety of
deeply-held historical and religious
reasons had been sent into Tel Aviv I
believe it might well have seen a
nuclear weapon popped into Baghdad
without much question so in that sense I
think you're absolutely right the issue
about how do we help work and I'm not
sure we can do a lot but how do we
understand the dynamics of deterrence
within the unstable regions of the world
they may not have anything doesn't
involve Washington at all how can we
understand the dynamics between Israel
which we I think much too easily have
permitted to become a nuclear power work
that deterrence within those regions is
one of those ants one of those questions
which I think plagues political leaders
throughout the globe into which there
are no good answers
well bye if I briefly respond to that I
don't think that there is a very serious
case it can be made to say what the
United States does with its nuclear
weapons program will influence what Iraq
Lybia North Korea or China do with their
programs most observers I think serious
observers have non-proliferation
certainly encounter the in diplomatic
negotiations the notion that if you take
do as an example give up all your
nuclear weapons give up all your nuclear
tests but that will help us do it
India being a prominent nation which
makes such arguments I think it's really
not really credible what is driving
these nations to acquire their weapons
capability is not the presence of the
United States but the presence of the
regional interests that they have and
indeed I personally not convinced that
the world would be a better place if the
US had zero weapons and other nations
had a few second third question there
you're whoever feels like we're
answering is that for me that's for you
consider it your well it's always
possible there are lots of things to
worry about in the world I've never
thought of that as being at the top of
the list but terrorists don't get their
weapons from nowhere usually is some
organized entity which develops a weapon
tests it produces it stock piles it and
then eventually maybe it finds its way
into the public domain and then
terrorists can use it so far the record
on terrorists has been relatively empty
if you mean biological and chemical
weapons first of all you could worry
about Mad Men well mad people generally
don't cooperate with each other so
individual and to do most of these
things require some cooperation so
perhaps that's why we don't see that
organized terrorists who aren't
individual mad people usually have a
political agenda
I shouldn't be sounding like any kind of
expert on this but I I would say that
they usually have a political agenda and
simply causing fear and terror and
destruction doesn't match up with most
terrorists groups agendas they want to
obtain the sympathy of somebody and so
long as there is a worldwide abhorrence
of those weapons they risk losing the
sympathy even of the group that they
wish to to get to do something that they
want so I don't know if this really
works but I would come to the conclusion
that maintaining a species wide taboo
against certain kinds of weapons can
only help keep terrorists who have a
political agenda from turning to such
weapons as tools for achieving their
political objectives
but other than that I would like to say
a couple of things first of all one
thing John said about the Treaty I
certainly agree with its verification
provisions are imperfect it will add a
new tool and a valuable tool so we're
glad to have it because we won't make as
many Iraq type mistakes in the area of
chemicals with the treaty as we would
without them unless it leads us into
overconfidence but we should be aware of
that but it is a new tool it since
there's a debate as to whether or not
the United States ought to have backed
away from its original 1986 policy of
wanting to have what's called Anytime
Anywhere challenged inspection under the
Chemical Weapons Convention and there's
both there are two sides to this but
basically the United States does not
want to let any of its black programs be
captured so we want to retain the right
to be able to say you can't go there
we'll try to convince you some other way
that we're not making chemical weapons
there it even goes so far that whereas
the United States Chemical Manufacturers
Association has said that so far as
they're concerned they would be willing
to have all chemical facilities whether
they make beer or whether they make
plastics or whatever they're making be
subject to open access so long as
certain kinds of protections for
proprietary information but open access
for sample taking and negative sample
analysis is okay with the chemical
manufacturers Association but it's not
okay with the United States government
because there may be a few industrial
establishments were there black programs
and you can debate this back and forth
and maybe there are other countries who
wouldn't allow the Anytime Anywhere
challenge and we won't get them on board
with even less we stick to it I myself
would rather see more as much as
possible anytime anywhere and I would
ask rhetorically anyway a black program
is usually intended to make something
like a weapon or a defensive thing or
something so you could ask let's say we
could have that thing and it's gonna
work whatever it is glasses that can see
into people's minds or whatever you want
but if instead I could also increase the
capability which as John says is not too
good for finding out what other people
are up to
maybe that trade-off is worth it so it
should be looked at that way so that is
still an issue with the treaty but I
think that either way it's something
that can be fixed later we can make the
inspection better it's going to be a
whole lot better than what exists today
and we can make it even better the the
thing about the no first use that is now
in the treaty the article one now says
that under no circumstances first second
or in all parties renounce all use
forever of chemical weapons so that's
good and it was missing it's there now
finally as far as sanctions it's not
there there is a kind of empty article
where sanctions are supposed to get
plugged in in the bargaining that will
go on in the last few weeks of the
negotiations and there's a lot of talk
about them and it's a long subject and
there probably be will be some but they
basically will depend on what the UN
special Commission in Iraq depends on
the reason that they were able to stay
in that parking lot with their documents
you know the reason we found those
documents was probably because nations
make mistakes
the Iraqis apparently thought that all
the cases which said to top secret don't
look at in the basement weren't there
and when the special Commission got
there they're in the basement for all
these cases full of top-secret micro
films and the first time they took them
all and put him in the truck in the
parking lot so the Iraqis came and took
it away they got it back some of it but
the next day after they kept on taking
this stuff they distributed a little bit
in everybody's clothing so that by
direct television link they were able to
say to the Iraqis okay if you take it
we're under instructions not to resist
for violently but you'll be seen taking
these things from all of our clothing
every we're all 40 of us and the
Security Council will know this with a
speed of light because we are a direct
link my point is that if there is a
Security Council that backs these things
up especially if the permanent members
of the Security Council what a new world
order there'll be a new world order and
if a very powerful nation doesn't
it won't happen so it's extent it will
depend very sensitively on what the most
important Nations want to do and finally
about the developing world in chemical
weapons the advantages of the treaty if
I were talking to a purely
self-interested American audience it's
very simple in this world today there's
high-tech weapons and it's very low-tech
weapons and there's all kinds of stuff
in between the thing about high-tech and
weapons is we're the only ones and a few
other industrialized nations that can
afford them
there are lots and lots of people who
can afford the low-tech weapons so
naturally it's only common sense to say
let's discredit low-tech weapons let's
deal Ajith amaizing let's prohibit them
let's get rid of them and then nobody
will able to have war except us and
maybe even nobody would be even better
but I'm not joking that's a serious
self-interested argument why have more
players who can do bad things on the
other hand this doesn't mean that a
developing country should be opposed to
the convention because who are the
victims of chemical weapons usually poor
countries time after time every time
there's never been a case in which
chemical weapons have been used against
forces who initially had any gas masks
in other words they're used against poor
unsophisticated forces and usually the
threat today will be from other poor
relatively unsophisticated forces so for
them it's a good deal too so that's why
I think we're gonna get the chemical
treaty even India and Pakistan impatient
to see the chemical treaty come along
are now having bilateral talks about
having their own verification etc on
chemicals so I think we're gonna get it
I do think that one great pity would be
if it allows and it's not just tear gas
we want we want to roll that way back in
caps and I agree with John its military
peanuts and to open the door to what
could possibly be dragged through that
door by insisting on that could be a big
mistake yeah yeah I like to make a
couple observations in full to stop you
this goes back to the issue of whether
madmen cooperate an expert the first the
first point I want to make is is that I
do think that the inspection issue
really has to be looked at kind of
careful I mean are chemical
manufacturers associated Association
United States some of my best friends
the moment that they saw that this was
not a device for EPA to get measurements
on their plants also realized that it
was not and that's a serious I mean I'm
serious about that you could you could
imagine such information being used for
a lot of purposes that would distress
them I think they they really you know
the chemical manufacturers of Germany
France England the unites they're just
not going to have a problem with these
kinds of inspections and on the other
hand going into a modern chemical plant
and inspecting it on a challenge basis
is a big deal and you really have to go
through with some amusement some of the
test inspections to get a feeling you go
to one of you know one of these places
by you Choctaw Louisiana and try and do
an inspection on a plant it is a major
problem I mean it requires more than
just cadres of chemical engineers and
analytical chemist it's a lot of work so
it's not so easy to do and everything
has to work right and things don't work
right big deal
matter of a covert is really where I
have a problem and it's not that I mean
I agree with Matt I think the world the
United States and the world is better
off having this treaty than not but in a
covert inspection you have what you
believe your policy system has led you
to believe is an accurate picture note
that the United States doesn't always
have accurate pictures even in areas
where I advised them have accurate
and now in order to actually tell a
country and by the way we want to come
in there and we're going to make it
stick
that is big political news and I see no
evidence that the world is prepared to
do that the concert of Nations let's
take the example given India and
Pakistan are now in an absolute frenzy
of affection on the issue of chemical
weapons treaty but if you want to talk
to them about inspecting nuclear
facilities especially the Pakistanis you
will find that they are quite unwilling
to have nuclear inspectors even
International Atomic Energy much less
people you know they don't really to
have it and and and if you try and make
it a political issue the first people
will say back off is our own State
Department because they say we have many
too many other important issues to deal
with with respect to Pakistan than to
blow it all on such a minor matter as a
proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction so the issue of inspection
took in in the Carter Administration it
was the carter administration who backed
off backed off from making pakistan own
up to its enrichment facilities because
of the they felt that having pakistan
favorable the united states position in
the matter of afghanistan was more
important than to make an issue of
enrichment that happened in the carter
administration so the point I want to
make is with the inspection it's not
just saying and this mat I'm just
reinforcing what Madison it's not just
saying anytime anyplace it's being sure
that you have the political depth
domestically and internationally to
actually do something about it to make
it stick we'll take one last question
that I've been promised will be very
brief because we're right about the time
we'll need to close
hi i'm jonathan king i had the privilege
to serve on the committee that organized
a technical briefing for the third
review conference in Geneva and I just
like to share with you many of you may
be interested in actually continuing to
ensure that these the treaty stays in
force and it remains effective there are
gray areas the government does have to
funded programs the BDR P the biological
defense research program with many many
many contracts all around the United
States many in the Boston area and
Congress has authorized the be ATF the
biological aerosol test facility and
Dugway Utah R at this very moment
hundreds of microbiologists faculty at
University of Utah Medical School
University of Utah itself are still
engaged in dueling with the army over
whether that should develop and the good
features that matt has developed have
depended upon quiet but constant
pressure on Congress from members of
primarily the biomedical community the
physicians for Social Responsibility
nationally have a conscious monitoring
program of BW the Federation of American
scientists which Matt you're not sharing
if this was played a key role in has it
had an active committee and I worked
with a group of more than a thousand
scientists who have signed a pledge
saying we're gonna try to strengthen
this this treaty and we watch what our
congressmen vote on on these issues and
let them know that not just Matt and
John but also average working scientists
in their districts right
competing with the military for
biomedical research funds do not think
this is a good thing
I just might mention that that network
is actually based in Cambridge at 19
Garden Street the council for
Responsible genetics and if you want to
join in and receive regular updates and
you want to let your you want to be
aware of what our government is doing on
this you know we welcome you and it's
easy and these are professional issues
they should be in the professional
societies graduate students should
that were signatories to a treaty and
it's a good good treaty and should be in
the business of the professional
meetings Thanks either of our speakers
since Jonathan mentioned some
opportunities for people to do something
I was in Washington last weekend there
is a program in fact most agencies of
the government whereby faculty members
junior or senior who want to get
involved in these things in Washington
for a year working for the United States
government there's a program by which
you can do that in this particular area
of chemical and biological arms control
I know of several open positions also
people who have a PhD who are interested
not just in a year away but in a career
I know of several open positions and it
it's a fascinating series of problems
and there's probably no time in our
country's history when there's been more
opportunity for a creative thinking
about how to deal with some of these
problems so if anybody's really
interested and doesn't know how to go
find those things themselves I'd be glad
to help you the hour is late then it'll
be time for us to close just now I'd
like to simply say that when Jerry Fink
and I began discussing the possibility
of a series like this some time ago it
was because there was a sense perceived
on our part that our colleagues on the
faculty postdocs we knew the graduate
students all had an interest a growing
interest in fact in understanding and
talking about the social issues that
related to our science but was outside
the laboratory and very pleased tonight
to see so many people from so many
different areas turn out to confirm that
that is indeed the case the goal of this
series both tonight and in future
lectures will not be to try to provide
answers advocate any particular
positions but really to try to squarely
address hard questions and principally
to be enlightening to provide
information so that people can go on
from here and think about things and
perhaps take some active role in those
things our next speaker will be Paul
Billings speaking about genetic
discrimination it's a speaker I know
well and I think will again contribute
to that but for tonight I want to
especially thank the to speak the our
speaker and our discuss and done a
wonderful job of enlightening us about
this very complicated topic with there
very sober and very important comments
thank you very much for joining us
[Applause]